le panthéon à l'arrêt du bus 89 c'est là
que rosa et patricia deux mexicaines se
sont donné rendez vous pour aller dîner
patricia débarque tout juste du mexique
prose à elle a fui le pays il y a trente
ans après avoir été torturé et si
patricia apprécié de visiter paris by
night elle n'est vraiment pas là pour
faire du tourisme
je suis venu dénoncer les injustices qu
on a subi à son salvador d atenco en
2006 c'était le 3 et 4 mai
patricia est en mission pour amnesty
international depuis cinq jours dans
plusieurs villes de france elle a
enchaîné les conférences pour raconter
son histoire une histoire oubliée
pourtant relayé à l'époque par les
médias du monde entier
le 3 mai 2006 à san salvador d atenco
une manifestation pacifique pour
soutenir les paysans tourné à l'horreur
3000 policier aux méthodes radicales 200
personnes emprisonnées humiliations
tortures viols en série et au bout du
compte sur vingt policiers arrêtés 15
était blanchi
ce soir pour patricia pas de discours ni
conférence en public juste un verre de
tequila en petit comité chez brigitte
bénévoles à amnesty international
c'est une chemise des biens de l'état de
oaxaca
c'est la braderie
mais derrière les sourires lors d'une
soirée à priori détendue les souvenirs
douloureux ressurgissent
pendant que je montais les policiers me
frappait à tour de rôle et
ils nous ont empilé les unes sur les
autres dans le bus
ils nous ont forcés à nous mettre face à
terre avec les mains sur la tête
calmos une épaisseur et leurs toros et
l'asthme annoncé la caresse les mâles en
scène et on est resté comme ça dans
cette position pendant cinq ou six
heures ville mons a scellé sa possession
ils ont continué à nous frapper
ils ont violé cinq ou six femmes pendant
ce temps là on est descendu du bus on
est arrivé à la prison ils nous ont
frappés la bosse moi ils m'ont violée
dans la brise le témoignage de patricia
réveille les vieux démons de rose à 30
ans auparavant elle aussi a été
confronté à la violence à l'époque c'est
le parti national révolutionnaire qui
était au pouvoir une dictature déguisée
en démocratie qui se met la terreur
c'est ce que les suisses et les la teuf
teuf avec la l'électricité on les
appelait les pick and electric 1 c'est
pas comme il s'appelle ici mon c'était
déjà pareil dit nous débattons qui met
l'électricité dans tout le corps cette
simple qui cueillait celui partout vous
laissant les oreilles le pied des
doubles et tout le corps
le lendemain matin juste avant de partir
pour l'aéroport patricia est venu prier
à notre dame avec un ami mexicain
[Musique]
m
même le concept
[Musique]
aujourd'hui elle repart au mexique mais
elle va continuer à témoigner à travers
le monde car quatre ans après les
événements tragiques la sphère d'atenco
n'a toujours pas été reconnue par le
gouvernement mexicain officiellement
faute de preuves dans un centre culturel
une autre mexicaine laetitia cloutier
marie à un français elle est à paris
depuis 20 ans issu d'une famille de
politiciens de l'opposition
laetitia aussi a été confrontés de près
à la répression son père a tenté de
dénoncer les liens entre pouvoir et
mafia
candidats la procédure du mexique en
1988 et il a décédé
dans ce spectacle si dans deux voitures
qui n'a jamais été élucidé parcequ'elle
il n'a jamais des investigations
aujourd'hui son frère manuel député
mènent le même combat que son père sur
son ordinateur toujours branché sur
internet laetitia prend des nouvelles du
pays via processo le site du quotidien
national mexicain montfrin a dénoncé que
dans l'état de sinaloa la lute contre
les trafiquants de drogue n'a pas été
faite d'une façon efficace et les
pressions de la république était très
fâché contre ces déclarations
mais qu'est ce qu'ils risquent d'
instable
vainqueur
c'est à dire que
je m'en vais penser qu'un jour le
mexique est un pays dans lesquels
[Musique]
la sécurité c'est citoyens pour être
garanti à quai la justice pourra
être utilisé pour
notre justice
loin de ses proches laetitia elle ne
fait pas de politique c'est par l'arc
est laissée d'exorciser elle promeut les
artistes contemporains de son pays pour
donner une autre image que celle de la
carte postale mexicaine je passe ma vie
à faire la promotion de la culture
contemporain du mexique loin des clichés
les mexique comme un temps énorme parc
d'attractions rempli des pyramides des
mariachis 7 et killer